yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
why haven't you gotten a vpn yet visit
expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
i don't know you know that we've
inspired people i just know that we're
doing what we believe
is right and what we believe somebody
needs to do
i want to get money out of politics so
actually
fighting corruption and reforming our
system and
doing things to stop the threats to our
democracy i think that that's
incredibly important probably now more
than ever what universal basic income is
going to do is it's going to
really really improve and you know
have a huge spike in entrepreneurship
you're gonna see
kids across this country start new
businesses that will give
birth to jobs of the future jobs that
you and i haven't even
thought about can't even imagine right
now having compassion in and of itself
isn't enough
you need to take action otherwise it's
just a meaningless word that makes you
feel good but doesn't actually do
anything and so
we need to elevate the level of love and
compassion we have for humanity
into meaningful action to get them the
support that they
need and deserve the basic human dignity
when we come together
that and we tell authentic stories about
how policies and politics impacts our
lives
we can actually make a big difference
and change people's minds on really
important issues
[Music]
zach this week we have a very special
episode of yang speaks where we're going
to talk to a bunch of the
congressional candidates that humanity
forward
has endorsed and i'm pumped for this
because
here at yang speaks we like to talk
about
the work that people are doing
and right now one of the most important
things that we can be doing i think
everyone knows i feel this way
is pass cash relief for people we need
to get cash into people's hands
and so i've been doing what i can to
beat the drum
with current members of congress but
this being america and politics being
politics
one of the best things we can do is
actually get people into congress
that believe in cash relief or if
they're already in congress
then get them to lean into it so
humanity forward has backed
at this point uh maybe 15 to 20
candidates around the country and if we
get behind them and they win their races
imagine waking up
in 2021 and having dozens of members of
congress who are part of a cash relief
caucus that is something that we can
make happen
and that's what we're working on right
now that's what this episode of yank
speaks is about is some of the
candidates
who we think could become part of the
cash relief caucus
and helped pass pandemic relief in an
early version of ubi
this is i'm not i don't wanna i'm gonna
make this declarative statement i'm not
sure if time isn't true but i think
we're the only podcast
that endorses candidates unless maybe
like bernie had a podcast for a little
bit or hillary did um but other than
that i think
we are which is exciting and i think
there's two reasons to listen one
is that there's so much noise out there
about what's happening on the ground
and so these candidates like a lot of
noise about texas turning blue so
having donna on to talk about what she's
seeing on the ground as a candidate
i think is fascinating if that's
actually a realistic outcome the other
thing is one thing i learned andrew
on the trail was how important down
ballots are
both during a major election year like
2020 but other years too
and having looked in the mayor's race
for us in new york
everybody has an opinion about bill de
blasio not even just in new york city
but outside but only 12 percent of new
yorkers actually vote for
that race because it happens in june
the year after an election year like
it's june 2021 i believe is that primary
of next year so this stuff matters and
this is how
change actually gets done it's not just
your big name candidates we all know and
love and hear of but it's the smaller
ones that actually
get seats of power seats of influence in
seats of change and we're hoping to
change that would you agree andrew
yeah i would and i think that there are
incredible opportunities in this race
uh this november because you're going to
see
uh turnout go up all over the place
uh and that could lead to outcomes that
people would never have thought
were possible even weeks ago so i'm
very very enthusiastic about our
prospects for getting some very
different types of
members of congress in but it only
happens that people vote
it only happens if people donate
volunteer
get behind them so i i've been
scratching my head about this a little
bit zach it's like um you know yang
speaks
i mean we like to talk about ideas here
um
and i love ideas but i'm more of a
worker than
anything else it's like you know like we
could all be talking about universal
basic income until we're
blue in the face but what's the
important thing actually getting cash
into people's hands
so humanity forward thanks to many of
the people who've supported us i was
already given over eight million dollars
and counting
in cash relief uh you know like it's
still happening
and then we can get members of congress
into congress who will push
push cash relief push cash relief
as a real solution and think about what
that payout could be
i mean you know it could be uh tens
hundreds of billions of dollars
in people's hands and we can be the
lever
we can invest in these races if you
donate you know i mean let's say like
uh in the aggregate thousands of dollars
to one of these congressional races
it can make a huge huge difference uh
and that's what we're gonna see play out
right now but we have to lean into it
um so for folks who are listening to
this podcast and think
like this podcast uh is
off of our usual format i mean you're of
course correct
um but this is the spirit of what we do
which is we're actually trying to make
positive things happen for people and
like it or not sometimes politics is
the best most direct way to do that
getting the right people into positions
of power and authority getting the right
people who will actually champion cash
relief in congress
you know it's not enough to like sit
back in your chair and be like oh i'm
right about something like you know you
have to do something about it
so we're doing something about it we
hope people who listen to this will join
us in doing something about it we hope
that one of these candidates
strikes a chord in you and you think oh
i really love donna or qasim or cara or
whoever it is
maybe you love them all um hopefully you
love at least one of them and you're
like oh i get behind this person and if
you don't love any of the candidates
that you hear today then i'm sorry
because they're very lovable
in my opinion there's probably something
wrong with you but but there are other
candidates
at movehumanityforward.com um
that you can check out and see who you'd
like to get behind i would encourage
everyone to at least get behind someone
because that's how change is going to
happen that's what we're working on
every day
so tune in we've got candidates we love
joining the podcast you can get behind
them too
tune in to a special episode with the
candidates on yang speaks
[Music]
one of the ideas that's stuck with me
for years is that
information is like food so you can
think of a quality documentary as like a
really
uh nourishing well-prepared meal and
then social media is
frankly a little bit like junk food so
you have to figure out where are you
going to get your
information from in a way that's going
to nourish you make you
think uh elevate you even and one of
our favorite publishers and sources of
information is the new yorker
they just invest in their content you
know it's like one of these premium
sources of journalism that digs deeper
it's not just like hey here's some facts
like they have folks
who dig in and find uh the narratives
they they break
some stories that and after they break
us then it just goes everywhere because
everyone respects the heck out of them
um some of their their writers are among
the best in the field
and i really appreciate quality
journalism the new yorker is one of the
sources that
i enjoy myself
the i the recent
i think they covered the coronavirus
outbreak in the white house really well
and really fair
um and then i think i was reading this
piece the other day um
on the lincoln project which may be
something you've been familiar with it's
basically a group of republicans
that have decided uh we're not voting
for trump and they talk like republicans
uh against donald trump and so um
there's a really fascinating piece about
the lincoln projects war room in there
that i just i felt like by this by uh
paige williams who's one of their
reporters i love but
it was just a fascinating um different
type of angle on uh
on the election if you will so um
it's why we love it we think you guys
will love it too and we've got a pretty
good deal for you so for a limited time
you can get 12 weeks of the new yorker
for just
six bucks out of the savings of 50
percent
six bucks for 12 weeks pretty great plus
listeners of this show recleave receive
a tote bag exclusive tote bag
for free get your tote bag we sold a lot
of those on the campaign you know you
have a use for a tote bag so go to new
yorker.com
yang that's n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r-dot-com
yang get 12 weeks in new yorker for just
six bucks and a free tote bag new
yorker.com
yang
[Music]
welcoming to yang speaks a man after my
own heart
entrepreneur congressional candidate in
florida's third district which is i want
to say gainesville adam christensen
welcome adam
hey hey how are you
adam i love your story because you are a
true startup guy
uh you started a company moved across
the country
for it uh and then you looked up at your
congressional representatives and were
like you know what like i think i might
be able to
to offer something and contribute and
then you
shocked uh expectations you became the
democratic nominee i think you may be
the youngest congressional candidate in
the country right now is that right
at least democratic yeah although i
turned 27 a couple days ago so i'm gonna
have to check again
not sure at this point well you're
up there in terms of uh youthful
[Laughter]
youthful candidates uh and your opponent
is
uh someone who i think she she worked
for the
former rep who kind of made a name for
himself
by being a jackass essentially
like he was like yeah it's funny how
these lines intersect but uh you can go
ahead and share the story about
uh i guess both the incumbent right now
who's
who's getting out of the way and then
your opponent
yeah so um ted yoho kind of you know
kind of gave us a gift he actually put
this race on the map
he's the one that verbally assaulted aoc
on the capitol steps
um he's also one of the four people who
voted against making lynching a federal
crime
uh and he also didn't like the
survivor's bill of rights the era
didn't think the uh what was it the um
oh shoot the voting rights act was
constitutional that's something that he
didn't think
so it was like all of these things he'd
been doing for years
but nobody really saw exactly who he was
until the aoc
incident at which point people started
to even realize that uh gainesville
existed and so that was uh you know
that's kind of
that was really where our campaign
really it was a jumping off point
honestly
it was a bunch of people that kind of
realized that you know this is the guy
who's been here for a long time
uh and we basically need to tear down
his infrastructure
with progressive ideas and preferably
with young people and it really just
shot off from there
now so tell us a little bit more about
the genesis of your campaign i'm sure
when you were first talking about
running people were like what
you know or thought that that was a lot
to bite off
but you ended up inspiring a lot of
young people in a college town
getting a ton of energy and then growing
from there can you tell us about how
you got started and really why you
decided to get into this race
yeah um you know one of the biggest
things for me i mean i
i always enjoyed politics like i just
enjoyed it and like i always thought
you know someday maybe i might try to
run for something
but i never really had any actual idea
about it uh and then you know tried to
grow past
as you know the startup stage where
effectively you get so big and at
a certain point you have to start
offering benefits to be able to keep
growing
and a lot of startups just cannot get
over that hurdle
and so that was one of the main reasons
that caused me to jump into this was you
know i had two companies and they both
got to that hurdle and i saw a bunch of
other small ones that got to that hurdle
and they either sold to bigger people or
they just you know petered out or or
they tried to get out of it
and so for me that's when i kind of
realized you know that
you know somebody needed to change that
and at the same time i was
i had looked and saw that ted yoho was
going to retire and so i looked and saw
who the democratic people were that were
running and i just i wasn't really
impressed
and i was kind of complaining and
somebody was like well you know what you
don't really get to complain if you're
not going to do something about it
and so my response to that was okay well
how would you get on the ballot
and so then i took the puppy out we went
out and tried to get as many petitions
as we could in the farmer's market and
within about two weeks we had almost 600
different petitions that have been
signed
and then i basically started talking to
people um and i sat down at a coffee
shop with
uh the person who became my campaign
manager his name's anton curnahan he
just turned 21.
he was an environmental activist and i
talked to him basically i was like
look like this is what i care about and
he was like this is what i care about i
was like well what if we give both of
those things a bigger platform and we
actually try to run
and do something here and he's like you
know what that's great
and so it started with one person and
then within the next couple days we had
about four
and then the next week we had 10 and
then eventually got up to 50
we're all under the age of 23 and
basically we were running because
we believed that things could actually
change and get better
and nobody else was going to do it and
so we had to
and that's really what we did
and what we've continued to do and i
don't know
you know that we've inspired people i
just know that we're doing what we
believe
is right and what we believe somebody
needs to do
and we're seeing a lot of support of
people that believe exactly what we
believe and i have just been waiting for
somebody to come out and say it because
they believed it for so long but nobody
has been willing to speak
truth to power and actually come out and
say
what they believe and fight for it and
so that's kind of what's propelled us so
far
i think yeah it's a it's a
very relatable story on several levels i
agree with you that startups have been
hindered by the the fact that we've just
put so much
on small businesses in terms of uh
benefits health care like i mean i've
run companies and it's true when you
make that transition where
you are providing full-on benefits to
folks and people are making
multi-year commitments to you it's a lot
of pressure
as a company and right now we made it so
that that pressure breaks a lot of
startups to your point uh what were the
startups you were involved with uh you
know i remember the one but i want you
to speak to it a little bit so people
get a sense of
what brought you here yeah so the very
first one that i started right out of
college i had about three thousand
dollars in my pocket
that i'd made from odd jobs working in
the summer on that on the drive
and it was essentially it was catching
international suppliers
trying to screw over family-owned
businesses and american businesses here
that were selling natural products the
second company really focused on kind of
the hemp and cbd industries
which are booming brand new industries
but have zero regulation nobody's
actually looking out for other people or
trying to hold others accountable
and so that was really what i was doing
and i kind of feel like it's a good
transition especially to politics
because that's what congressional
representatives are supposed to do they
are supposed to hold people
who try to take care advantage of those
in their community accountable
and stop them yeah there's a
well there's a lot of that going on
unfortunately which brings us to your
opponent
who has like this backstory that i'm
very i could muster be confused by so
it's like okay i get ted yoho
he's been there for a long time he's
like you know rich businessman lawyer
type
um and then but your opponent is not ted
your opponent
is his former employee
of some kind who worked in like a
communications
uh capacity is that right it's a little
fuzzy for me it's
very well here's the thing is it's very
fuzzy because it keeps changing
like every other day um so here's what
we know we actually
we went and looked into this person
because you know in
what i do is i essentially you know try
to look through marketing and bs and try
to see what is real what is not
and be able to actually know um and so
we started looking into this person
and the very first thing i said the
first commercial i ever saw her
was she goes i grew up on a cattle ranch
in colorado and obama bankrupted me and
i was homeless
and i was like you know that's an
incredible story i wonder if any part
of the incredible literally unbelievable
it's amazing
like you i love like i don't know who
you are but like you got me like i'm
ready for this story like i want to know
about it and so i looked into it
and i couldn't find the cattle ranch
like the
first most simple thing is i grew up on
a cattle ridge and i couldn't find it
anywhere no property records nothing and
so like we spent
weeks looking for this thing and then we
finally threw it out on twitter and
we're like
all right internet go find this because
we can't find it and whatever you find
use the hashtag hashtag where's the
cattle ranch
and tell us what you find and they found
so many things but they couldn't find a
cattle ranch
it was insane and so we eventually found
a piece of land
that was apparently bought by her mom at
one point but there were no buildings on
it
they never lived there so it was not a
cattle ranch on top of that they took
seven different loans out over 12 years
they had 350
000 in debt and eventually they were
foreclosed on
but it was not because of obama it was
because she went on a 108 day
cruise that cost 30 grand across the
world
and she literally caused her family to
lose their piece of land
on top of that it was right after she
graduated from college
and so she literally transitioned out of
college housing to an apartment
hotel and then joined ted yoho's staff
but she said that because she had lived
in a hotel she was quote homeless
and she said the hotel was so bad that
she called it quote a crack house
so literally everything about her was
completely fake
and this was before she even got into
politics and so right at that moment we
knew that
something like there had to be things
that had happened because this is not a
story that most people
have ever experienced or seen and so it
was incredible for us
um she was his chief of staff
uh she was 24 years old and about a year
in she was fired by ted yoho but he
refused to say
why and she was actually just she was
demoted and shipped back to gainesville
florida
when she got there the entire staff in
washington was
purged and she set up a consulting firm
while still on his payroll and started
receiving more money
while doing this than she was as a chief
of staff for a sitting congressional
official
and also her husband's lawn mowing
company started to receive money as well
and he still refuses to endorse her so
we realized something very
shady and sketchy was going on and
nobody
still knew what the incident was that
led to her being fired
and so this is who we're running against
somebody who's made up their entire life
story
everything about themselves and it's
just it's insane and nobody has ever
looked into it well
you know it unfortunately a lot of local
journalism has
uh withered and died and so not that
many people are digging in
all the source documents they have it
they've just refused to actually look
into it
yeah it's it's a tough time for uh
congressional candidates who are trying
to get a spotlight i've i've
seen this with some of the humanity
forward candidates including
you and and this is a republican-leaning
district
that seems like it could flip it's
interesting because ted's been there for
a while
um his uh your opponent um
i think many people just assume that
she'd sort of sleepwalk into the seat
even though as soon as you start
scrutinizing at any degree you're like
wait a minute this person is
like why is this person like the the
primitive favorite the republican
nominee to be a member of congress
uh and you are you know to me like right
on time like if you can get the support
and visibility you need
uh you would be such a fun
transformative
figure in congress uh we would have it
would be
fun well we see the
i mean we see eye to eye on many issues
um one of the things that i'm passionate
about right now
is championing cash relief during this
pandemic
and universal basic income longer term
but first things first just cash relief
like where are you on uh trying to get
money into the hands of people
after we get you into congress january
2021
well i i i think i've tweeted about this
quite a few times but my first response
is basically any stimulus package that
anybody wants to put out if it doesn't
have
cash relief at like a thousand or two
thousand dollars for people
that it should be dead on arrival it
shouldn't even be taken seriously and it
should honestly be retroactive
based on how much we should have been
getting for the last seven eight months
and so for me unless it has those
provisions i'm sorry but there is
literally no reason to vote for it well
hopefully we can get
some energy and resources your direction
to
save us from your opponent as member of
congress
and you as member of congress would
would be a blast
uh where would people go to get behind
you to support you to find out more
about you and your campaign
the biggest place uh obviously is our
website which would be for the many
not just me.com and that would be the
best place
our twitter and social media is ac for
congress 2020
we also have an email list and different
things but you know we just dropped a
jobs plan
that would essentially bring about 9 000
jobs to our district and it takes all of
our big ideas like
high-speed rail and broadband internet
and all of these different like small
business incubators
and actually makes it for our area
because we have these big ideas but if
we're not able to actually
create a vision that people can get
behind and actually see it in their
daily lives
then we're not doing anything that's you
know going to be actually substantial
and so that was a big thing for us is we
created this there's even we even
created a map where you could scroll in
and see different locations and
different things that would be happening
in our district
if we were to get into elected to office
and so for me that's what i'm focused on
i'm not focused on a 24-hour news cycle
like what's the most ridiculous thing
that you can make up and like
try to get people to care about it's
about people and it's about what we can
actually accomplish and
you know make our lives better because
that's what
we make our lives better amen adam amen
uh so so pumped for your race so pumped
for you to become uh the newest member
of congress out of florida's third
district
uh adam thank you for taking on this
challenge thank you for running uh it's
been
a joy to support you and your campaign
uh yeah let's just keep fighting keep
fighting in the the gap between you and
your opponent is very very
wide it's fun you know we've had a lot
of honestly most people don't have fun
when they run congressional campaigns
like they get to a point they're just
you know it's just not fun anymore and
we have had so much fun
literally the last two days because my
birthday was two days ago literally the
last two days have just been
phenomenal and like i have not stopped
laughing
pretty much for any point of them and
it's just you gotta have fun
you gotta love what you're doing and you
have to actually care about people
and if you're grounded in that you're
gonna do okay we'll be with you every
step of the way
adam uh really excited for you and your
race thank you so much
[Music]
we're excited that we're able to bring
you a company called noom
that has a long-term weight loss and
lifestyle improvement
um essentially strategy to help people
um like yourself get into the body or
shape or
lifestyle or mental health uh that you
like for me
like the example for me was that i
wanted to get more energy in my life
like i
coveted to me is just knocking me out um
and you know the same energy i had on
the campaign so
for me they've got lessons food logging
they can flex there's a lot of
flexibility in the app itself so you can
kind of customize a plan within your
lifestyle and then you have this app to
hold you accountable and it's pretty
amazing how it's
both psychology and the science and
the interaction with your daily life
specifically specifically on your cell
phone actually works to keep you
accountable for that so for me
i'm just starting this thing i'm working
on my energy and nume has been really
helpful
noon builds on science and it's been
scientifically demonstrated that if you
want to achieve a goal it's helpful to
have other people
coach you push you keep you uh in
in line and on track it's one reason why
those personal trainers work so well
where i remember when i was uh working
out in my 20s and i thought do you need
a personal trainer and then
you get one and and uh even for like you
know the free
thing the gym gives you or whatever and
you're like oh my gosh like that was
crazy
that's the kind of size that doom builds
on where they connect you with someone
who's going to help keep you on track
for your goals and a whole community of
numerous
and it's built not just upon action it's
built upon
science and psychology it tries to make
it easier for you to adjust
your behaviors to reach your goals
without just saying
goal goal goal all the time and it's
worked for a lot of people
already a lot a lot of folks have found
tests with noom
around hitting a goal and keeping on
track for that goal long term
it's not enough just to have it happen
once and then
revert back to whatever previous
behaviors or physical condition you are
in
so if you want to get in touch with a
whole community of folks
that want to help you achieve your goal
you don't have to change it all in one
day
small steps can make for big progress
you can sign up for your
trial today at noom that's n o o m
dot com slash speaks what do you have to
lose except for some weight
visit noom.com speaks to start your
trial today
that's oom.com speaks
[Music]
next up this incredible candidate
running in
nebraska she's a non-profit leader who's
been working with people
for years and now she's running for
congress i think she's going to win cara
eastman
[Music]
and now we have the amazing cara eastman
who's running for congress out of
nebraska's second district which i think
includes omaha
that's right right welcome carl welcome
welcome to yang speaks you and i met
when i was campaigning in iowa
um because for those of you who aren't
geographical
experts iowa and nebraska touch each
other
like right there yes and i i
said this then and i i you were the most
inspiring political speaker i'd ever
heard
talk so thank you for that it was it was
fun and you know politics isn't always
that much fun
politics is not that much fun but you've
been in the change-making
line of work for a long time um you and
i bonded over the fact that you also
started and ran a non-profit that did an
incredible work in your case it was a
children's non-profit based in nebraska
yep
it's called omaha healthy kids alliance
it still exists but i'm no longer there
i was hired to start it in 2006
and our focus was originally was
eliminating childhood lead poisoning and
then eventually we grew into a green and
healthy housing
organization well your
evolution is similar to mine in that you
run a non-profit and you see all these
problems
uh in our communities and you think wow
someone should really do something about
that and then you're like i guess it
might be me
because after you work
as a non-profit leader you kind of get a
sense as to
frankly like the need for different
solutions to solve the problems you're
tackling every day that's right
well and and these are problems that can
be fixed
if we have because we have the resources
to fix them in this country we just
don't have the political will
yeah well you're changing that tell us
about your race in nebraska for people
who don't know that much about it
and also and you can do this in order um
when did you first hear about universal
basic income
well um i heard about it from you on the
campaign trail
[Laughter]
so there's that but um yeah it's it's an
exciting race here
in the second district all eyes are on
us because
in 2008 we gave an electoral college
vote to
barack obama in nebraska we split our
electoral college votes
similar to maine and so we have that one
that some people are saying could be
the deciding electoral college vote it's
a little terrifying to think about but
could be true
and biden is ahead in the polls and as
am i and so we have a real opportunity
to elect the first woman to serve the
district
uh somebody i'm running against a trump
republican who's voted with him 93
of the time and also to give that
electoral college vote to get rid of
trump
wow you are up it is very hard to beat
an incumbent tell us more
like it sounds like uh has this guy been
in congress for a long time
he's in his second term and you know i i
actually ran against him in 2018
and came up 1.9 short in one of the
closest races in the country
so we're back again and we've given
people four years to see him in action
and he's betrayed the district over and
over again
and they're looking for somebody who's
actually going to represent them
wow you're going to make that that the
comeback it's like cara the return
you know like rocky 2 a little bit like
like the
the first race was rocky won we all know
what happens at the end of rocky 2.
rocky wins for those of you haven't seen
it
[Laughter]
one reason why i'm thrilled to get you
into congress is that you are for cash
relief during the pandemic and
someone who's worked with families the
way you have
you would be for casualty because you
understand the good it would do
in the lives of so many people in your
district
that's right we have so many politicians
in office in particular on the
republican side
who do not seem to understand the needs
of regular working people
and that you know most of us are one
economic
shortfall away from total bankruptcy
total annihilation of our family
and if that's in in the form of hitting
a pothole
and having your tires blow out when you
haven't
you don't have the money saved up to
actually pay for that which is
challenging to do because it's expensive
or getting laid off from your job and
now we see this in the middle of the
pandemic
where so many people have lost their job
and therefore lost their health care
so it's we need people in congress who
understand this
we need more working-class people in
congress the average net worth of a
congress person right now is a million
dollars we need people who understand
this stuff
and i've had the honor of working in
non-profit organizations for over 20
years my worldview is framed by the
clients that i've had the honor of
serving and i believe they deserve a
voice
so tell us about your race i mean you
came within a hair's breadth of winning
in 2018 and
what are you seeing this time we're
seeing a lot of change with independents
in the district about a quarter of the
district are registered independents we
started our campaign this time by
knocking doors of independence
in 2018 we knocked on 200 000 doors
around the entire district and so um and
what we heard from independents this
time was their number one priority was
getting donald trump out of office
so when we have a congress person who
has so heavily aligned himself
with trump and with the republican party
nebraskans are pretty independent look
we have a unicameral
we've had uh we've actually been a
prairie progressive state in the past
where we had
democrats as our governor as our u.s
senators
and and i think a lot of people have
seen that the trump administration's
failed promises have actually really
hurt nebraska especially in terms of our
agricultural economy
and especially in terms of that tax bill
which we know was not for regular
working people
i agree with you that independents right
now are looking up and saying we gotta
turn the page for our country trump has
to leave
and i think that's one reason why i am
so pumped
about your race and other races around
the country
that uh you have a wind at your back
this time
that i don't think has existed in my
recent memory
um so we need to get behind candidates
like you and make sure that you
you win i i agree well and and when we
look at 2018
people talk about you know the fact that
it was great that we flipped the house
but
you know 84 of incumbent republicans in
that in the house kept their seat
so i i would not describe that as a blue
wave but i think that we can have
that this time expanding the house
majority flipping the senate and
obviously flipping the presidency
uh the the i'm optimistic about uh
your race and many other races car i
think the toughest thing is going to be
after
you all get to congress is trying to get
that institution working
more efficiently and effectively than it
has been
in quite some time but it starts with
getting people like you in
having a non-profit leader like you
who's so close to your community in
congress trying to craft policy would be
such a quantum leap forward uh
and it is funny like talking to you now
i think other people
might have the same impression because
like you said most
members of congress at this point are
very affluent
you know a lot of them come from
business backgrounds
and backgrounds where they can plug into
like a network of money
and you come from a very different
background it's very very grass roots
driven the fact that a candidate like
you is poised to
make a bit of history political history
it sounds like in nebraska
is such a great sign for 2020.
what would your top legislative
priorities be after you get sworn in
because you're going to win and you're
going to get sworn in 2021 aside from
you know dealing with the pandemic in a
responsible way that actually
demonstrates leadership and prevents
human lives from being lost my two
priorities
are health care fixing our broken health
care system we're just
we have to start with lowering
prescriptions i'm running because my
mother was prescribed a 2500
pill that she couldn't afford to take
and i want to get money out of politics
so actually fighting corruption and
reforming our system
and doing things to stop the threats to
our democracy i think that that's
incredibly important probably now more
than ever
so many people agree with you on those
priorities i love them
it's economic relief fixing our health
care system
and getting money out of politics slash
tying our politics to people
my proposal as you know was give
everyone 100 democracy dollars
um so the goal would be to wash the
corporate money out
so it's not even quite get the money out
of politics it's more like tie the money
to what
ordinary people think um because right
now the number of people that donate to
political campaigns and if you're
someone who's donated to a campaign you
should know
that puts you in like the like maybe 10
of americans donate to political
campaigns it's probably risen this cycle
so let's call it 12
14 but that's still highly unusual
so what can we get that percentage up to
if everyone had 100 dollars and then
they said i like cara eastman
you know i'm going to i'm going to get
behind her and i've got 100 democracy
dollars to do so like what percentage do
you think we'd get up to
if everyone had 100 free dollars upwards
of 80
i mean i think people would actually get
engaged and get involved and
and one of the things that that struck
me and i don't ever hear anyone talking
about this so maybe we could
but when i first started running you
know they tell you like go to your
friends and family
ask for money right i did that like my
friends gave me fifty dollars it's
wonderful
but like what they mean is go to your
wealthy friends and family
and and go to corporate packs but when i
started looking at the lists of people
who donate to
democrats in our district
99.9 of those people were white people
and it was shocking to me that we have
so few people of color
who give to political campaigns so so
drill down that number even more right
and and we know that especially for
wealthier donors they often get
prioritized in my campaign we
we run on a grassroots campaign our
average donation is incredibly low we
have thousands of donors
but that's not typical this is actually
pretty different for a district like
mine
and just different in general because
it's not just republicans that have done
this it's democrats as well
so we need to change the system
yeah your the numbers are very very um
damning in this regard so i said let's
say 10 of americans donate and
those 10 are donating 50 bucks because
that's what a normal person would do
[Laughter]
if you drill down to people who donate
over 250
which makes you like a more serious
donor that ten percent drops quickly to
like i think it's one percent
[Laughter]
so uh and you're looking at the top uh
tenth of one percent that give like the
max of 2800
um in a federal race uh and so when
you're given
fun fundraising uh direction
about running for congress you need to
raise 1.6 million on average to be
successful
uh and so if you do the math on that
like
it's hard to get there on like like 20
bucks you know you need like a lot of
people so they expect you to go
chase down the folks who can give you
thousands uh and that's the game
and we need to change the game so that
you have more representatives that
actually answered uh
people that aren't in position to give
thousands of dollars
that's right and you don't we shouldn't
have candidates or
elected officials spending time doing
this this is not
how i mean you don't want your congress
person spending six hours a day raising
money
well you don't want that but
unfortunately it's the norm uh lawrence
lester excited a study that said that
members of congress spend 30 to 70
percent of their work hours raising
money
so that's six hours a day like that's
not an exaggeration that's not a car
just making it up i mean that's real so
cara
people want to get behind you and help
push you to victory
uh on november 3rd uh where can they
they find out about you and how can they
help
eastmanforcongress.com on twitter at
cara for congress kara with a k
facebook at eastman for congress or
instagram at cara for congress and
we can use all the help we need money we
need volunteers
we need people just to spread the word
on social media whatever you can do
right now
the value that gets generated in the
last number of days is like a lot of
things in life where like a lot of the
last mile value is the most important
so it's not too late to help cara
cara eastman nebraska second district
give help volunteer text bank phone bank
and
we're going to be in position to
celebrate cara's victory you're going to
be such an incredible member of congress
and i am pumped for it i'm pumped to be
a part of it
thank you that means a lot coming from
you i appreciate it i appreciate you
carl let's win
[Music]
if you're looking to keep your data
private a virtual private network
is a must now which one to use i can say
with a lot of confidence that expressvpn
is the best vpn on the market it's rated
number one by wired the verge
cnet and other experts a lot of high-end
companies
use expressvpn and you know those folks
are sticklers the ctos
are all like this is the way to go
expressvpn doesn't log your data
some of the really cheap or free vpns
actually still are data brokers trying
to make money off you i know
isn't that messed up uh the second big
thing is speed expressvpn
you forget you're even using it because
the speeds are just so fast it just
feels like you're using the internet
wherever you are as opposed to from
another server
and the other thing is ease of use it's
like a
set and forget it hit the button and
then you're off to the races with some
advantages the advantages of
anonymity security and sometimes access
to content you wouldn't have gotten
otherwise
to protect yourself with a vpn that yang
speaks uses and trusts
use my link expressvpn.com today
and get an extra three months free on a
one year package that's expressvpn.com
yang visit expressvpn.com to learn more
in virginia's first district kasam
rashid
is running for congress uh and he's a
very compelling guy an incredible life
story
uh has been doing work in civil rights
uh trying to fight for people for
years causing rashid
[Music]
welcome to yang speaks the awesome kosa
rasheed hey costume how are you
i'm good andrew how are you good to see
you it's good to see you too
so i feel like you and i had a a bunch
in common
where uh are you an immigrant or the son
of immigrants uh i'm an immigrant
i'm an immigrant i was four
you were four it counts man it counts i
mean uh you must remember
uh arriving here um but the other thing
we have in common is that we both have a
legal background
uh though you became a civil rights
lawyer um
and uh community activists uh whereas i
did something much more so
sucking for five months you know i i did
the corporate i did the corporate law
thing for
a couple of years uh because you know
you need the
paycheck to pay your student loans but
you're right it can be soul-sucking if
it's not the right fit for you and
that's what helped me make the ultimate
jump to
civil rights and human rights work
full-time yeah so tell us a little bit
more about the civil rights legal work
that you did over that period of years
because you built like a very strong
following on the basis of fighting for
people
yeah you know i think a lot of it goes
back to what my parents ingrained in my
siblings and i at a very young age so
whatever you do in life
if you're not centering service to
humanity it's really a waste of your
life and that was the word that they
used
and so as i got older that was the lens
with which how i looked at everything
and going to law school really opened my
eyes to
kind of understanding the incredible
role the law plays
in whether people have basic access to
decency and dignity or not
and uh in law school i got involved with
a non-profit here in virginia
called the virginia poverty law center
their office of domestic and sexual
violence
and so it started from a very um early
point in my legal career supporting
women who are survivors and that's
pro-bono work i do
through this day um i started working
with non-profits on expanding health
care and education access on disaster
relief was a prison chaplain
and you know all this to say that um
when you get to understand how folks are
struggling on the front lines
you really begin to understand and you
know on the theme of you and i having a
lot in common andrew
you really begin to understand that
these aren't republican or democrat
issues
these are basic human issues and it's
critical
that we stand together and work together
and address these one of the most
rewarding jobs i had was at a women's
rights organization in dc
where we were able to work with the
department of justice and other
various government entities on just
ensuring and advising that the policies
being put before
really do give people equal access under
the law that's really what this has to
be about
yeah you're a humanist and humanitarian
first and foremost i feel
it's one reason i like you is that
you have a very elevated perspective on
a lot of these issues
you're running in a relatively rural
part virginia
that's been somewhat republican leaning
but it's going purple right now
i think you've got a great chance to win
i think you're gonna have a lot of wind
at your
back uh can you tell us a little bit
more about
your opponent um and your district and
the race the state of the race
how's cawsom race shaping up well so the
race is going great let me start with my
opponent
career politician he's been in office 34
years and
uh you know pretty heavily corporate
funded uh
hasn't really made the most kosher
decisions financially bought himself
stock in a pharmaceutical company
working on corporate 19
treatment way back in february and then
told us the virus is low risk and not
spreading and you know his
entire approach this entire campaign has
been to attack me for my faith try to
tie me to islamic terrorism and just all
sorts of ridiculous things
that's never been my style and we're not
going to respond in kind
this is a district you know if you visit
virginia you get to
really see southern hospitality and this
is a district where people really
enjoy being in each other's company they
enjoy uh you know talking to complete
strangers and
there's this sense of civility and and i
think honor and dignity in the folks
here that i've seen
where even if you are from a different
perspective or different faith or
different racial background
you're treated with a lot of respect i
really enjoyed that about living
in virginia and raising our children
here the race
has been going extraordinarily well and
the early voter turnout
shows us with a massive lead about 136
000 votes have been cast so far and
we're looking at the polling that we've
done
on people who've already voted right now
we
are getting over 70 percent of the vote
and so for us
it's about you know continuing that uh
that trend pushing folks
to the polls making sure we're winning
the folks on the fence
and we're having event after event where
now
uh republicans and trump supporters are
showing up and we're welcoming them in
and it's been a really powerful
experience so far
i had the same experience on the trail
costume where i would show up places
where there were frankly not like you
know that many asian americans
in some of the early states but people
will listen to you uh they'll realize if
you're there for the right reasons
um people just want to be respected and
heard and if you respect and hear them
then they'll respect and hear you
and then they'll figure out it's like
wait a minute this person actually
uh here's my experience it's like they
they spend some time with you
and they realize that there are only two
possibilities one that you're
an absolute crazy person or two that
you're genuinely there to help
and then when they get rid of number one
they're like wait this person is
actually sincere
and that's that's very very powerful
stuff like you know we can draw in
people from
uh both sides of the aisle because
americans
in my mind are unified and being fed up
right now
uh you know and they're like different
strains of uh fed upness
but the the fed upness is near universal
and if you seem like a genuine
um public servant and humanist who wants
to help them and their families
they'll support you well and we saw that
yesterday we had an event
uh here in the district which about you
know 30 people showed up not a massive
event but certainly not tiny it was a
good
good
crowd and and we had a big rasheed for
congress signed behind me
so folks who were trump supporters
started driving by honking you know
trump 2020 with the trump flags
and and you know we ignored it and then
a whole bunch of them
showed up carrying a trump flag uh and
just kind of yelling and screaming
and i paused the event and i had the
microphone so i
i kind of raised my voice to the trump
supporters and i was like hey guys you
don't need to yell
you can be part of this conversation too
why don't you come on in
and i think i caught them off guard
because i think they expected me to kind
of shout them out i said
come on in let's have a conversation i
got their name one the guy's name was
chad and we actually had a pretty
meaningful conversation
um you know i refuse to respond to the
vitriol but at the end of the day
after the event ended andrew out of
these 30 people five of them walked up
to me one by one
and said i'm a lifelong republican i
have never voted democrat in my entire
life
i feel like i don't really have a party
i wasn't sure where to vote
but now after seeing the way you treat
people even if they disagree with you
you've got my vote and i'm like that's
brilliant because that's exactly
what i'm trying to build there are so
many people who feel politically adrift
right now because if you're a lifelong
republican and you look up at
donald trump and you say this is not
what i signed up for like you know i
voted for this guy last time and like
this has been a crushing
disappointment and uh so then they're
looking around and saying what do i do
and
you know you presented the right kind of
unifying figure and message for them to
say
like he's sincere he wants to help uh so
casam
you are for cash relief like after you
get to congress when's the first time
you
were exposed to a universal basic income
uh like when did you first hear about it
you know so i'm a student of history and
there's a great book by michael hart
called the 100 where he ranks 100 most
influential people in history
um it's a great way to sound really
smart by only reading like a five-page
excerpt on every you know major figure
in history and
and number 52 uh was
uh or is he ranks a person named omer
who was a second caliph uh after prophet
muhammad and omar was
not just a religious figure but he was
an economic genius
and he introduced this concept of ubi
about 1400 years ago
uh to the you know the arabian peninsula
and to the islamic
empire at that time and it was designed
to be exactly that you know
a guaranteed form of cash payments to
working families to ensure that they
could have a basic level of
livelihood and it helped ignite the
economy and that's actually why michael
hart
dr michael hart ranks him as number 52
because of his economic genius and that
was one of them so
for me this principle is something that
i was fortunate to be exposed to at an
early age
and in my research and study not only
was i
excited to find out that we were close
to passing ubi in the united states back
in the 70s under a republican
president no less but if you look at all
the studies around the world
you find consistent study after study
demonstrating that this not only
uplifts people out of poverty but it
ignites the economy
it advances entrepreneurship and
innovation it creates upward mobility it
decreases rates of suicide
and depression and mental illness and
elevates senses of well-being and just
the overall human
experience so i see every reason to push
forward for this
i haven't uh seen a single valid reason
to to oppose it
yes and you're exactly the the person
who's going to help us pass this thing
when we get you into congress and we'll
all be around and say well
no wha what do we do to restore
a path forward for millions of americans
but also to reconstitute a sense of
public trust
and i've organizations and
it's very hard to just go around asking
people to
for their buy-in or their trust or their
confidence unless you
actually uh step forward yourself and
invest in them like if we as a society
say look
you everyone has intrinsic value your
kids have value
you matter uh and we're not just gonna
[ __ ] you and talk about it like
we're actually gonna put our money where
our mouth is like that is actually
the transformative
change that people will respond to
because
they're just you people talking to them
and not doing anything and then if you
actually do something that
meaningfully impacts and improves their
life then it's a game changer
and we can make it happen like you're
going to be one of the people that
helps make it happen from the halls of
congress starting 2021
after you win this thing after you win
um what what district are you in
virginia and if someone wants to help
you and support your campaign where do
they go how do they help
we're the first district of virginia you
can go to our website uh
rashid for va.com i'm on social media at
casimir sheet just my name
really really easy to find and to add to
your point i mean there's a reason
andrew that our campaign slogan is
compassion
through action that having compassion in
and of itself isn't
enough you need to take action otherwise
it's just a meaningless word that makes
you feel good but doesn't actually do
anything and so
we need to elevate the level of love and
compassion we have for humanity
into meaningful action to get them the
support that they
need and deserve the basic human dignity
food water shelter
healthcare education and clothing and
for those who want to get involved in
our kind of a campaign i don't care what
side of the political aisle you are on
if these values matter to you
check us out rasheed for va.com sending
us an email to organizing
rasheedforva.com and we will get you on
board
yes they will get you on board uh i love
it
uh and you're you're beyond a humanist
and human
humanitarian you're like a grand doer
and i love the doer part
because you're right um the only thing
that makes me feel better about a
problem is doing something about it
and we just need more americans to have
that same
uh approach because things suck right
now but if we all did something about it
uh we could improve things pretty
quickly and one thing you can do that's
very straightforward is help
candidates like costume get into
congress where they can actually
uh pushing uh the laws of the land in
the right direction
thank you cause um really man i feel
great about your race i think there's
gonna be a very powerful
uh wind at your back that's gonna help
blow you
like forward across this metaphorical
finish line
um and you're just getting started it's
awesome thank you man good to be here
[Music]
good
you know a lot of people have been doing
during the pandemic like
before drink their sorrows away
i'm not really that big of a wine guy
but evelyn is and so we've had bottles
uh around um the home
and it's actually i gotta say um it's
it's become like a
kind of covid um
ritual i guess in a way that
it was not before and if you're looking
for
a way just to have wine sent to you i'm
a set it and forget it type of guy this
would be a great present for evelyn
g's um i'm uh maybe she doesn't know
it's true
but yeah uh but you get 50
off your first bottle orders from bright
sellers
that's bright sellers c-e-l-l-a-r-s
dot-com and if you put in the code
yang 50 you get 50 off six bottles
of wine i mean that's a pretty good deal
you can take their seven
question quiz to get a sense of what
wine
that you would love and if you don't
know whatever you know like i don't know
[Laughter]
you could receive 50 off your first
bottle order of six bottles
wow six bottles of wine that would help
one drink the sorrows away
so for podcast listeners only getting
fifty percent off your first six
bottle orders from brightseller go to
brightsellers.com
50 that's bright seller c-e-l-l-a-r-s
dot com slash yang50
take your seven question quiz to get
your wine matches and receive 50
off your first six bottle order the
bright cellars is a wine subscription
that helps you find the wines you love
without the normal intimidation and wine
pretentiousness that you're used to
trust me i know this because i'm an
idiot when it comes to wine so whether
you're a new wine drinker someone's been
drinking for wine for years
brightsellers
pairs you with unique wines based on
your taste profile i just did this you
fill out the seven
question quiz it actually has pictures
you don't have to read you just click on
the
pictures you like um and create this
exclusive experience for you and then
they send you a box of wine and it comes
with education cards i guys i literally
just got this today
i'm pumped to try it it's got tasting
notes where the wines come from and if
you want to sound like a wine snob you
can like share to your friends and be
like oh did you know it comes from the
xyz calistoga region of napa and this is
why it's got the
tannins or whatever crap you want to
make up but bright sellers is awesome so
it's bright sellers
c-e-l-l-a-r-s dot com slash yang
50 get 50 off your first six bottles
donna eimum's one of the first
candidates we got behind
she's an engineer who's been working on
automation issues and job training for
years
she's running against a guy who's been
in congress for
decades and decades and has not
accomplished a whole lot she's running
in austin texas which is an area
that is going increasingly purple she'd
be a phenomenal member of congress
she's very very data and solutions
driven donna imam
[Music]
welcome to yang speaks one of the first
candidates we endorse donna eimum
out of texas's 31st district which is
the
austin surrounding area welcome donna
hey thank you so much for having me
andrew it's always
so exciting to talk to you i love your
perspective on things
and the way you talk about them so
simply on twitter is really amazing
i'll thank thank you donna you're you're
so kind you and i have a lot in common
that you're
trained in engineering and
worked in automation related issues for
years before
ever heading near congress uh tell us
about how you came to realize how our
economy is
changing so fundamentally yeah so you
know i always tell the story about when
i first started out as a development
engineer
that every single manufacturing worker
in my company
was laid off some of them never worked a
day in their life again
can you imagine that right uh none of
them had any job retraining
options at all to be able to you know
take their skills and go into something
else
and this economy what it does is it
creates this
enormous amount of economic anxiety
even if you have a decent job because
you don't know at what point which day
you'll lose it you know all of a sudden
and you're kind of left with nothing
and so my background you know is in
technology but in 2008 2009 when this
entire country
had the you know had was going through a
recession
austin had some of the lowest
unemployment rates and i saw people who
were well educated
that were basically being foreclosed on
or didn't have health insurance for two
three years while they were
still trying to land a job and so about
six or seven years ago
i joined a non-profit and that
non-profit provides free training and
education for
anybody who wants it it wasn't thousands
of dollars in debt but we built it up
into a four thousand member non-profit
and what i realized through that
experience
is that we can do much more we can bring
better solutions to make sure that
people don't face this kind of anxiety
and that's what led me to run for office
and you know as you know you and i met
in early
march 2019 before i had announced and
one of the things that i
loved about your platform when you ran
is you
brought attention to these underlying
root causes of these problems
and that's why i took the trip out there
to go meet with you
when i think most of america hadn't
heard of you yet
that's true early 2019 uh the yang gang
was not what it is today uh and you ran
as a first time candidate
and shocked everyone when you won the
democratic primary
in part because turnout surged well
beyond anything that had happened before
and now you're in position to track down
and beat the incumbent uh
in a purplish area tell us about how
your district has changed and what
you've seen on the ground
over the last number of weeks well first
of all andrew
i have to give it to you and your team
you
are kind of the lone trailblazer blazer
when it comes to
looking at texas and recognizing how
critical
our race is to turning texas blue so
when i talk about
turning texas blue my district as you
mentioned is north austin and all of its
suburbs
so it encompasses all of williamson
county
and almost all of bell county other than
three precincts which are
in texas 25 and what i've been talking
about as you know
is that more than 65 000
new voters new people moved into this
district they tend to be
younger families with children they tend
to vote democrat
and here's the interesting thing we just
you know october 5th is the last day
to register to vote in texas and so we
got the voter registration numbers from
williamson county and bell county and
guess what
over this last two years since
2018 we had an increase of about
exactly 65 000
new voters that registered imagine that
this
race was lost in 2018 by only 2.9
percent happened to be 8 000 votes at
the time
but here's the kicker of this story that
you're going to love
right now across entire texas
if you look at the top 30 most populated
counties
williamson county has the highest voter
turnout how amazing is that and remember
in the primary we talked about how we
increased
you know the the primary um uh turnout
by 233 in the primary and 257
in the runoff and we were like that
shows a lot of enthusiasm
amongst democrats and we're seeing that
play out right now
and i hope the states you know uh stays
alive all through the
first you know the three weeks of early
voting that we have
i'm excited i'm pumped i think we have
this amazing
opportunity at uh flipping this district
blue
and believe it or not andrew you put us
on the map on the national map
oh that's so kind donna you put yourself
on the map by uh getting out there
and making the case to the folks in your
community your opponent
uh he's in his 70s how long has he been
in congress
he's been in there he's a nine-term gop
congressman
and believe it or not while in texas we
right now see corona
virus cases spiking we have the second
worst death rates in all of the united
states
we have people that are on the edge of
losing everything right now many
families
they've lost all the unemployment
benefits right and guess what he's
tweeting about
he's boasting about the fact that he was
able to get three
billion dollars that's billion with a b
of money
for the border wall do you think anybody
in texas who is struggling to pay their
rent today
or is challenged they can't buy
groceries to put on their table
is thinking about the border wall yeah
they should get three billion dollars
into the
the hands of the families in your
district uh and i i know
you've been one of the earlier champions
of cash relief
uh and uh universal basic income
um your opponent really does seem like
the sort of person he's frankly
uh like your polar opposite in so many
respects
where you know like you're like a data
driven uh
solutions oriented type i love the fact
that you just busted out all the numbers
for your district like you know done
like a true
um uh a true math person um
would uh let's talk about uh trying to
get cash relief into people's hands
uh after you're sworn in as the newest
member of congress and that's going to
be such a joyous celebration
because i really do want uh people to to
see donna
engineer first-time candidate shockingly
won the democratic
primary now is uh is in position to
ride a wave of support and all these new
voter registrations to upend
think he's 74 john carter iii not like
18 years
in congress sort of republican trump
rubber stamp
uh after you get to congress in 2021
um what are your top priorities and is
cash relief one of them
absolutely so you know my biggest
priority for texans as you know
we texas has the most number of people
with no health insurance and no health
care whatsoever
across this entire country so health
getting health care to people in texas
is very very high
on my priority list but i'm a huge
proponent
of uh universal basic income and here's
a reason why
what universal basic income is going to
do is it's going to
really really improve and you know
have a huge spike in entrepreneurship
you're going to see
kids across this country start new
businesses that will give
birth to jobs of the future jobs that
you and i haven't even
thought about can't even imagine right
now and this needs to happen
if we're to stay you know the most
developed country in the world the most
technologically advanced country in the
world it is important
for us to continuously innovate right uh
decade over decade over decade and we're
seeing some of that innovation die right
now by the way
uh andrew if you see the investment in
ai and machine learning
the majority of it right now is not
being done in the united states and i
don't know if the american people are
aware of this
that it is important for us definitely i
think this is a huge
amazing topic that you've brought into
the national conversation
and i feel honored to be part of it and
i want to
hold that flag we also need to get you
know debt-free education
so kids can pursue these types of new
new types of jobs and new types of
technologies
yeah we've made education way way too
expensive and i agree with you that a
lot of the top
uh research and innovations being done
outside of the u.s
we've made it harder through a whole
number of reasons
and then to the extent the work is
happening here in the u.s the average
american doesn't feel
like they're being included in the
progress and prosperity and so they'll
answer to some very bad leadership
um so we have a lot of work to do but
you know you're
uh chasing solutions to the biggest
problems of our time and that's one
reason why i think you've captured the
imagination of so many people
uh in your district where they meet you
and they're like this person could be my
congress person
you know they're probably used to like
the john carter the third
kind of i mean like to the extent they
even like have thought about it
and a lot of them are brand new to the
district where they just moved there and
then they're like who's my congressman
man or woman and then you're like well
it's it's him but it could be me
yeah so this is an exciting race as i
said
uh the voter turnout here is just
exploding
and right now we're on top so i see a
strong pass to winning
and i can't wait to take these ideas
that
some of them that you've brought to the
national stage and other ideas that
to make our health care system better to
make it less expensive
to scale our infrastructure to get more
primary care physicians in
i want to take these ideas to congress
we're going to make it happen andrew
you're such an inspiration to so many
people including myself
i really really hope we flip this
district and show
the rest of the country that we can do
this especially with folks like you
behind our campaign
i think we're going to get there your
your race is very important i couldn't
agree more donna if someone wants to
help
you get out the vote uh or
volunteer in some way how do they best
reach you or how can they find out more
please go to our website sign up at
vote4donna.com
and sign up to phonebank we are trying
to touch every single voter
uh in different ways uh whether that's
through you know
sending them a piece of mail or sent
leaving literature but also having a
conversation with them
so help us have those conversations we
want to get every single person out to
vote we want to make sure that
they understand that when they vote they
are
in charge of their future we want to put
everybody's future
in their hands so they can make a
determination come out and phone bank
for us
and if you can donate please donate we
would love to have your support we're
one of the
you know most grassroots campaign you
can imagine
we have tens of thousands of donations
and our average donation is less than 50
dollars if you can imagine
i can literally count the number of
people that have maxed out on our donate
on our campaign so imagine that this
weekend we're
trying to do a big lit drop in bell
county to make sure people know
uh what our campaign is all about the
solutions that we're bringing that talks
to the
challenges of latino americans and the
hispanic americans and mexican americans
and
black americans belle county is a
majority minority district so
if you can help us out you know donate
five dollars ten dollars it helps us
support our poll breeders get them
donald literature as they're walking in
you know so they know and they go and
inform and they can vote donna
so we would love to have your help and
hopefully uh you'll have some wonderful
representation
someone that you can be really proud of
policies that you can really get behind
vote for donna.com let's make it happen
texas31 thank you donna you inspire me
uh and uh i remember you know the
last couple weeks on the trail uh you
know you
you uh uh you don't show at all like the
the
level of activity you put in um for the
last number of months because you've
been working hard for a long time
but the work's about to pay off we can
help make it pay off for donna go to
vote for donna.com
let's help her win let's give ourselves
cause to celebrate
on multiple fronts not just the top line
of the ticket
but in texas in michigan
in nebraska around the country let's do
it thank you donna
you're making us proud you're making the
yang gang proud you're going to help
move humanity forward i can't wait
thank you andrew i really appreciate it
in michigan john hodley is running for
congress in the kalamazoo area
uh i like a lot of things about john
he's been an activist small business
owner
he's also been a state legislator for
six years so he
has a sense of of how legislation can
work to improve
people's lives and now he wants to take
that to congress
john hodley
[Music]
i am thrilled to welcome to yang speaks
the congressional candidate from
michigan's 6th district mr john hodley
welcome john
it's so good to be here thanks andrew
i'm a fan of yours
in part because you're a small business
owner i think small business owners
understand what's going on
in our communities better than just
about anyone you've also been a state
legislator in michigan which i also
think is a fantastic uh
training ground because you get you get
like the
good the bad and the ugly can you tell
us why you got into
politics um in the first place
i should start by saying my my family is
that of like teachers and educators so
both my parents um were professors my my
sister my cousins aunts their teachers
and you know i watch over time how
that's
the profession has really changed
growing up back then my parents
paychecks were enough
but my sister actually ended up having
to leave teaching
because it barely covered her paycheck
barely covered the cost of child care
and and i found myself that you know
really stuck in this idea that
we should be investing in the things
that help us with the public good
and then personally um you know i
my some of my first experience with
experiences with politics
were having one of those school bond
issues um
on the ballot and having it fail and
then
thinking who votes against schools but a
ton of people do
but actually my friends and i we started
knocking doors uh and talking to people
about it when we were in high school
and we got it passed the second time and
so it really showed me that if we do
work we can make change
and that became very personal for me
when
i came out and was doing work on
lgbtq equality issues before
the national conversation was really
happening but i saw with all of that
when we come together
that and we tell authentic stories about
how policies and politics impacts our
lives
we can actually make a big difference
and change people's minds on really
important issues
and so i've been doing that ever since i
started a business and helped people do
it so i know what it's like to make a
paycheck to
buy health insurance pay taxes and then
ultimately
i ran for state representative thinking
about how can i take those skills and
advocate for even more people
on these big issues i feel like it's a
really big
decision to run for a state rep um what
does that look like in michigan like how
much did you like what did you have to
do you'd be like i'm gonna run for state
rep
well you know i think it's one of the
things that for folks that are thinking
about getting involved you know
raise your hand because there are people
that want to help you
and uh you know running for state
representative in michigan
meant that i was going to be serving 93
000 people
and in the kalamazoo area and for me
that meant knocking on a whole bunch of
doors
because it turns out if you talk to
people and ask for their vote they like
to have their opinion heard and they
want you to do something about it
and you know frankly it's part of what
we did to replicate our run for
us congress now you know we said well
since our current or the current
representative doesn't do town halls
let's go meet with people since the
current representative
only does very short meetings with folks
who write big checks
why don't we actually try to go and get
more voices involved in the campaign
and it seems to be paying off tell us
about
your uh opponent so you're in the state
house you're doing your thing
we talked a little bit about this uh
michigan somewhat unusual in that it has
term limits i believe
uh of a certain duration um and so you'd
look up and say wait a minute like my
congressman could use an upgrade
sixth district so who is your opponent i
believe he's the incumbent
um and uh what does the race look like
yeah so you're right by the way michigan
has the shortest strictest term limits
in the entire country
um and you know when you look though at
someone who's been in office for
34 years like congressman upton you know
you start to wonder perhaps
that's a bit too long and you know
especially
if we had term limits i can verify that
they'd be shorter than 34 years
we all agree on that though so if um
you know especially when it looks at the
the issues that
he's choosing to spend his time on or
the issues that he's avoiding
doing any work on and you know for me it
was all about
healthcare my partner chris has multiple
sclerosis
and so we know what it feels like to
have to fight with an insurance company
who oftentimes has more power over your
treatment than your doctor or you do
that that's essentially every american's
living nightmare that unfortunately has
come
true for for way too many of us
absolutely right and then
you know i'm like we get it everyone who
is sitting there at the start of the
year thinking i sure hope my insurance
if i have it covers the medication that
is keeping me healthy
you know and every day i will tell you
someone is telling me a new story about
how they're fighting with the insurance
company to get a prescription covered
and then denied and then they're
supposed to pay
obscene amounts out of pocket or they
worry that i mean it's just all messed
up
and my member of congress actually voted
12 times to deny coverage for people
with pre-existing conditions
he voted against lowering prescription
drug costs so i'm not sure why he
expects people to vote for him
this time around especially during a
global health pandemic incumbents have a
great win rate no matter what they do
more or less
you know i mean like they've got a win
rate of 90
plus uh it's one reason why i love
getting behind folks like you who
uh would be a massive upgrade again over
over the incumbent and just need people
to have a chance to
see you and meet you you know if they're
in michigan sixth district in the
kalamazoo area
um so they can do whatever they want a
lot of the time and when you say like i
don't know how he expects people to vote
for him it's like well
he figures he's got like a seven digit
moat uh
and and maybe it like maybe a district
that is drawn in a way that that would
uh make him more confident
well and we got lucky because we were a
harder district to gerrymander since
they couldn't move
lake michigan or indiana but this is
going to be a fight all the way to the
finish line i mean like you said
dealing with incumbents are hard to beat
but we're on track to do it
so a couple of big pieces the polling
has been really constant
uh fred upton has hit a ceiling he's
never getting above 46 47 percent
and despite the republicans and outside
groups
running what's been called the most
homophobic campaign in the country
and lying about my record as a state
legislator we've actually been closing
ground
so we are within the margin of error on
the poll he's up a few points on us
and now moving into the home stretch
here's what we know
195 000 people have a ballot
have requested a ballot in my district
that's huge
because 330 000 people total voted four
years ago
of that over a hundred thousand people
have already returned their ballots
we're going to have
a huge voter turnout and by the way a
big chunk of those are first-time voters
and when you look at the undecideds in
the race the biggest thing that we're
seeing in the data
is essentially they know enough about
the guy that's been there for 34 years
they would like to know a little bit
more about me
and so when we are and when we're still
calling voters when we're still running
ads on on the internet on tv
it's actually helping people know who i
am and that story why i'm involved
so we've got a bit of a funding gap for
this last you know
few days and frankly at this point
contributions are huge
because it lets us ramp up and continue
to go into additional segments
of voters who just don't know enough
about me
yet but are inclined to vote for me if
they do we expanded our voting rights in
michigan
so this is going to be the first
election where
everybody can vote by mail if they want
to where anybody can do same-day
voter registration so some of these
things that take away
the power from the incumbent to actually
put it back in the people's hands
they're on we're going to be able to use
them this time and this
feels like the year where people
definitely want to see some change
uh yeah the your uh your race is one of
the most important uh
fascinating races in the country in my
mind because it's michigan it's a swing
state
you know you're in a competitive race
and district everyone knows that i ran
on
universal basic income where are you on
cash relief during the pandemic and
thereafter
well that's one of the things i really
like about you and it's an idea that
i've talked about for a while because
you were actually for for universal
basic income even before i came along if
i remember right
yeah and it's a it's an important part
of this conversation especially in a
place like michigan that's had to deal
with automation outsourcing i mean a
number of issues
that we just haven't been able to
respond to as fast as we need to
and then the rest of the country saw
really firsthand
how we put band-aids over the current
global
health pandemic where you know we're
asking people to delay evictions
but we didn't find a way to backfill
those uh those lost revenue
and i'm a legislator i've served in the
appropriations committee
i know very well what is facing us
in terms of all of the downstream
impacts that this is going to have
and how so many of these things could
have been avoided with having some
consistent predictable basic
cash relief um like by the way so many
other countries did
throughout this pandemic the reason why
you're such an ideal member of congress
is you're just genuinely
a caring person who wants to improve
people's lives and if we put you in
position
of power like i know you'll just take
that as your framework being like hey is
this going to help the people in my
district and
if so great and then if not why are we
talking about it
that's right i mean right the idea that
we should put people in community at the
center of the decisions being made in
washington dc
shouldn't be a novel concept but
unfortunately
it is groundbreaking in a place like
michigan's 6th congressional district
but
hey one last thing for everybody
listening we're seeing huge movement
here for anybody that wants to help us
um talk to voters call text we've got a
ton of opportunities over at john
hodley.com
on the join us tab um and you know we've
got people that are connecting with
voters every single day
and it turns out it's making a huge
difference and we need your help to get
over the finish line
so just john hodley.com that's john
h-o-a-d-l-e-y dot com if you want to
help john
get into congress and beat this 34-year
republican incumbent who
i suspect has not been doing a great job
for quite some time
[Laughter]
that's what we're hearing that is what
we're hearing thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you